that's not the plan
um you obviously have a very close
relationship with Jay Prince
um who is you know
you know listen he's a Pioneer we talk
about pioneers he kind of kicked off so
much for so for so much of
just everything we see now we think
about rap a lot records and he kind of
laid the blueprint on how to do this
label thing for a lot of people
um you helped him with his book like how
did you and him end up becoming a point
to where he could kind of confide in you
and Trust to kind of help help with his
story
um I mean I've known Jay
um for a long time I mean definitely
like
2005-ish when I started going out to
Houston pretty heavy um this is when you
know Pimp C was uh coming out of prison
and he was doing a lot I think rap a lot
was through Asylum at that point yeah
yeah so yeah yeah because Adam would
send us a lot of work um because they
had they had all the southern [__] yeah
they had all a lot of Texas artists were
really having their moment and that was
one thing I kind of went into the
history of that in the book this ended
up being just more more than just see
this kind of Southern rap in general
um actually what happened was that
Southwest wholesale which they started
Distributing rap because of UGK was like
the first album that they actually
distributed it wasn't something they did
before right and it showed them this
could be a really profitable business
model so for all that time between I
want to say early 90s and 2005.
all these Texas artists had access to
Southwest wholesale which was selling
like hundreds of thousands of units
without them being signed to a major so
you know the slim thugs right you know
all these guys had access to a
distribution Outlet where they can make
a lot of money and not have to go
through a major
um certain things transpired and
honestly it's been eight years since I
wrote this so I don't remember all the
specifics but it's in the book um as far
as on the business end how Southwest
fell apart
um they went out of business or I think
they just went bankrupt and so at that
point that's why all the Houston artists
started to get signed around 2005
because now they didn't have it because
they didn't have the distro yeah so they
had to go get deals and that's why you
saw this explosion of art yeah from Star
Trek and then Swisher house was it right
right everybody I feel like Asylum
really had a Texas yeah
but yeah so I got to spend a lot of time
with Jay around that time just being in
Houston I mean if you're in Houston like
you kind of have to you know he's he's a
part of everything out there so we've
heard but to his uh to his credit
definitely I mean he would always kind
of take me under his wing and just you
know not he's not someone who's gonna
you know
I want to say give you like a lot of
instruction but it's more like he'll
just kind of let you watch the way that
he handles situations and I'm that's how
I like to learn anyway like just you
know just I just like to observe so he
would allow me to kind of be around for
a lot of business type situations and
just kind of observe how he handles it
and so I learned a lot that way and I I
don't know
um for a fact you know if this was a
factor in in him putting out his book
but I did a chapter on J prince in in
the pimpy book yeah um and it's
I probably went like a little left field
with it I mean I definitely put a lot of
extra context but I just felt like it
was a great story and it also helps you
understand
um what was happening the time when
pimpsey got arrested it was I believe it
was nine days earlier there was a
congressional hearing or maybe it was
the Senate I don't remember
um there were large government hearings
about rap a lot right I remember hearing
about because there was a huge like dea
investigation they were determined to
find and they couldn't find anything
yeah and they were following him and I
mean I remember he told a pretty crazy
story on Joe Rogan I was just like yeah
it's pretty crazy yeah yeah
um
the Senate is part of Congress right I
shouldn't know this let's be clear no
Congress this is I know this isn't a
politics I know Congress and the Senate
are different that's a part they're the
part of the judicial branch
Congress is the Senate but yeah right
you're right the Senate hearing would be
it was a congressional Senate hearing I
think I'm saying that correctly there's
there's like a 300 I don't it's like a 3
400 page transcript of that hearing is
like the craziest thing I have ever
found on the internet and I read it all
like this is [__] amazing I have to
make this a chapter but when you
understand you know Pimp C at that time
he's beefing with Master P he's running
around talking a lot of [__] he's
wearing a rap a lot piece and the DEA
has been investing like they spent who
knows how much money they had all these
agents on full-time payroll for like a
whole summer trying to find something
unravel up so they're investing a lot of
money the federal government
the Houston Police they're investing a
lot into try to find something on this
company and so pimpsy is representing
this company
um well and he and so he got an
altercation with a woman at a mall and
all he did was allegedly like flashed a
pistol at her because she's she said
something about Master P oh I don't [__]
with you I [__] with Master P and he
showed her he had a pistol in Texas
that's aggravated assault really he
never touched her she wasn't injured
right it feels like that she was a
booster history it feels like a not a
non-texas thing to be aggravated I feel
like in Texas
in Texas they they'll they'll give
they'll give you a tax break if you
flash your gun yeah well now it is back
then it wasn't for sure back then well
he just had he had really terrible
timing when you look at you know what
was happening in the criminal justice
system mass incarceration the dea's
investigate rap a lot so it helps you
understand how he ended up in prison
over this relatively you know minor
situation but I say all that to say you
know my book came out and then uh Jay I
believe had done a draft of his book
right with uh Jasmine Waters and so I
think it it may have prompted him you
know hey if I don't tell my story you
know it's somebody else somebody else is
going to tell it and you gotta Tell Your
Own Story yeah you got to control your
narrative so when I talk to him I mean
the the whole
you know rap lot from the beginning has
always been about doing it independent
for sure same as ozone so he obviously
he's in a position where he could get a
publishing deal and you know get a check
to just put it out through somebody else
and I said well you know that doesn't
really fit your you know the rap-a-lot
spirit let's not the rap about way so I
had learned a lot about the distribution
side doing my own book nobody wanted to
give me a publishing deal for Pimp C
everybody in New York Publishers like
who what pimp so I put it out myself
learned a lot
um and so
I basically helped him create a
publishing Arm book publishing arm of
rap lot to put out the book no fire
independently so yeah I that was a great
uh we had a great run doing doing promo
and stuff for that we came and did your
show yeah yeah I was gonna say is it
because because I think when it did The
Daily Show that was the highlight for me
I was wanting to go with Trevor Noah was
a Jon Stewart yeah shout out to Trevor I
love Trevor Noah I don't know who's into
it now actually it was BET Awards
weekend we
that was a crazy weekend we did so what
was that to a 20s Awards after party
2018 2019 2018. yeah I think that was
the year I climbed over the fence to get
to Jamie Foxx's house might have been
the year maybe it was a year yeah had to
get into the after party anyways like
I'm gonna hop this fence up and then
went to the airport to fly to New York
to do The Daily Show and yeah that's
crazy
with like so now we see Jay Prince he's
he he'll get on social media now right I
gotta say that was
he didn't want to have an Instagram I
set up his Instagram
because now he's into it now he'll be on
there he'll be in he'll be I don't know
if that's I don't know if that's him
personally but he'll be by the pool
he'll be you know
I I love when Jay Prince throws his like
you know he'll put his little like it'd
be wise if you stood down you can read
in his voice right like what he just
said about the NBA youngboy Drake think
it was like I just hear it hear him
speaking like I'll read the caption in
his voice as I say what would in your
opinion be or not even in your opinion
but as you know him something that you
think is the biggest misconception about
J Prince because I feel like when I met
him he just seemed like such a nice guy
and I feel like when we think of Jay
Prince we think of this like figure that
you got to go to Texas you gotta check
it with Jane Prince or his son and but I
feel like there's a whole side of him
that not a lot of people probably see
that's a good question I mean
I mean he's he's a very smart you know
really really smart guy knows how to
maneuver and um
yeah I don't he's not a big you know
Boogeyman or anything to me I mean I
guess if you listen to internet
commenters and that might be the that
might be the perception but um I mean he
he also was I mean I want to say one of
Floyd Mayweather's first managers so
he's like
yeah he's he's he's got a he's got his
hands in a lot a lot of stuff um
definitely very Savvy businessman and uh
yeah he's been good to me shout out to
Jay Prince